director Shannon Reed from the New
Hampshire community
college system
and the floor is yours
thank you very much we appreciate the
opportunity to speak with you this
morning you have in front of you
materials about the community college
system
more likely than not I'll go off script
though because I'm not very good at it
my colleague director Reid will try and
keep me on task
I'm trying to figure out how to make
good use of your time my there's a lot
of material in here but I think probably
the overarching themes I want to share
are access in terms of affordability but
also opportunity
community college system is seven
colleges serving each region of the
state and there are some common elements
to the work we do and then there's some
components that are are tailored to each
of the regions that we serve and and
that local commitment the understanding
of needs of communities is is a central
theme for our work one of the
overarching themes as I said is access
and one of the ways that that manifests
itself is in terms of affordability
I know that this committee has probably
heard representatives of higher
education come before you and
tell you that we're 50th out of 50 and
support for public higher education
we are Partners in this and the support
that we've received from the state over
the years is actually critical to
affordability
you have enabled us to keep tuition
virtually flat for more than a decade
and we are reaching a point now by
combination of your support and and
fiscal discipline
where you may hear other states talk
about free college promise programs
we're on the cusp of perhaps being able
to do that for the State of New
Hampshire by keeping tuition flat by
making it accessible we've allowed the
federal government's Pell Grants to
catch up with us over the last decade
and we've got some additional analysis
to do but you know part of the reason
that that's important is that if I come
in here and I tell you we're 50th out of
50 in support for public higher
education
what does that tell you not not very
much but what it tells a prospective
student a high school student and their
family is opportunity is Out Of Reach
that's not the message for us the
message for us is that the future is in
Focus we can help you get there
one of the core components of the work
that we do is not simply on our campuses
our dual enrollment programs running
start e start in partnership with vlax
Early College Programs give students who
are academically ready for the challenge
the chance to begin college and in fact
in this current year we'll probably see
about 8 000 students participate in that
program earn about 40 000 credits of
college level work this year
if all of those students were to come to
the community college system of New
Hampshire
that would save those families almost
nine and a half million dollars they're
out of pocket cost if they paid fifty
dollars a credit which is the rate for
running start would be about two million
dollars and it's almost a five to one
return on the investment but in fact
you've already invested for students
taking stem and CTE courses they pay
nothing out of pocket so I I can't even
calculate the math of nine and a half
million dollars against virtually
nothing we've actually made a request
this year representative Ladd is
sponsoring a bill to expand that because
we'd like to do more
majority of those students who take
running start and dual enrollment
programs don't come to the community
college system only about one in ten
will come to us they take those credits
elsewhere and it saves them and their
families in University system if that
were a student at Plymouth or Keene or
at UNH that's between 18 and 25 million
dollars of savings but the downside is
that most of those students are just
taking one or two courses because that's
the limit of the scholarship we're
proposing to make that up to five
courses a year so a student could who's
academically ready complete a full year
or more of college before they finish
high school not to Simply get to the
Finish Line faster but to save money to
avoid the loans that often become a
barrier to other things they want to do
in life
so a lot of the work that we're doing on
behalf of the state and the state's
students and the families is in
partnership with you to create that
affordable Pathway to post-secondary
education
and it doesn't mean every student goes
to college every student needs to go
right to college but young people don't
want to lose ground with their peers the
idea of having a year of college or even
a semester of college in the bank that
gives them the time and the courage to
do something else whether it's military
service whether it's to try a job that
that maybe is something that they're
they're interested in but to not feel
rushed to run to college knowing that
they've already made some progress
toward that degree again that that's
more typical for the students that we
actually do serve on our campuses
students who are more likely to be
part-time students living and working in
their communities here in New Hampshire
and fitting in education around their
lives
as as as employees as in some cases
parents are caregivers so again part of
the role the community college system
plays is is weaving into the lives of
students so that they can stay enmeshed
in their communities
yes thank you can you go back a little
bit to the the
tracks of the programs that these
students who are proposing that they
were taking in our year of college when
they're still in high school what kinds
of courses are those and what are those
courses preparing them for thank you
well it can be virtually anything about
uh 20 of the courses are typically
college level English courses could be
first-year composition it could be a
literature course about 20 are typically
math courses providing students with in
some cases more rigorous math
instruction than they can necessarily
have in in high school and those are
courses that are broadly applicable
about 10 of those courses are in
business for students who Aspire in that
direction but it can be almost anything
we have students taking courses in
advanced manufacturing and precision
manufacturing we have students taking
courses in Psychology
you name the discipline in almost
anything for which there's academically
qualified teachers available to
participate we can support instruction
you're welcome
thank you Mr chair and thank you Dr
woodstein for taking my question
um last session we increased the amount
of funding for running stat program I'm
a huge fan of running start and um I
just my own two granddaughters started
uh school with a full semester because
of the participation in running stock
courses
um but how much I think Mickey if I'm
correct
um we added 3 million
in the last biennium I'm not sure I
remember Karen and I discussing it but I
I can't quite remember exactly how much
it was but
um I know we're not in the budget
conversation right now but if you can
help us how much more
because this to me is one of the major
factors in reducing the overall cost of
parents sending their children to
college if they can get a semester or
even a year
um and I don't know if people realize
what velax does uh kids can actually get
an associate's degree
simultaneously as they're getting their
High School degree do you have any
happen to have any numbers about kids
that have accomplished that those are
more it happens but those are more
anecdotal in the sense that it's this
student and we can name them literally
because it's so few there are a handful
of students who will take a full year or
even two years and complete the
associate degree concurrent with
receiving their high school diploma a
majority of students it's one or two or
three or four courses over the two or
three years of high school where they're
participating so not necessarily getting
the full benefit that they could
particularly for those students who are
academically chat you know they want the
challenge they're ready for it and the
high school doesn't necessarily have it
otherwise available
um that second question
um
the high school might not have the
courses
do all our New Hampshire High Schools
offer running stock courses virtually on
Hotel we're in over a hundred high
schools but what courses are available
is impart a function of whether the
faculty the teachers in those schools
are qualified to teach because our
accreditation requires certain uh
credentials to those team ministers yep
part of what we've requested in a bill
that representative Ladd is sponsoring
to this point the support has been in
terms of scholarships to waive the 50
cost we've asked for some additional
resources to be able to actually partner
with high schools to provide faculty who
can teach courses for which the high
school doesn't have somebody who can do
that oh great that would be so we're
trying to be a little bit more creative
in meeting the needs that students could
um
again I'm reluctant to take somebody you
know Slide by slide through a slide deck
but if I could take you to slide seven
when I said earlier that we have
benefited from a partnership with the
state what you're seeing is tuition
essentially flat over the last 12 years
if we had allowed his consumer inflation
to run its course tuition instead of 215
would be almost 280 dollars a credit
by a combination of your support for our
work and as I said the discipline that
our folks have in managing resources
we've kept it virtually flat and over
that time the value of a Pell Grant
Federal support for students with need
has increased to the point where this
year unless something changes it will be
virtually sufficient to allow us a
student who's receiving full pal will
cover the cost of attendance at the
community college system not everyone
receives full pel you could receive a
partial pal we're trying to Fair how to
help those students manage the expense
as well
but the overarching theme that I said
about affordability running start is not
means tested any student so for students
in the middle class we're not going to
receive federal aid for college other
than loans running starting or other
dual enrollment programs or the
opportunity that we can help those
students and their families manage the
cost of college and last year House Bill
1530 which created a requirement of
Pathways between the community college
system the university system
creates an on-ramp that helps students
if they participate in running start
through those Pathways with us a more
affordable way with Assurance of
completing a more affordable degree and
staying here in New Hampshire the
majority of college-bound four-year
college-bound students in this state
leave the state for college if we can
give them more reason to stay here those
on-ramps to the community college system
the university system we can perhaps do
a better job of holding on to New
Hampshire's young people keeping them in
the state for education in the workforce
after graduation so again this is a
reflection of yes our work but our
partnership with you because these
things are our combination of funding
but also
ah
is why it's good to have Kali with me at
the table still on that slide the third
the third block that's there I mentioned
earlier in response to representative
Murray's question a significant number
of the courses that we're offering
through dual enrollment tend to be in
the areas like English and math and
business which frankly are kind of the
affordable ones to offer because you can
have 20 or 25 students in a class with
one faculty member doesn't require a lot
of equipment
what's in what's happened over time is
as we've done more with dual enrollment
and we've seen uh enrollment shift more
of our work is concentrated in programs
that are the expensive ones to deliver
our nursing programs each credit of
nursing instruction between 650 and 700
a credit
even though the students are paying less
than 300 including fees for that course
our dental hygiene program the only one
in the state for dental hygienist and
assistance the revenue that comes in
from that program
leaves about a million dollars of unmet
expense to deliver
if we enrolled the clock back four or
five years when we had more Liberal Arts
students more business students and
about the same number of Health Care
students the math worked out reasonably
well we've gotten to the point where our
programs are increasingly concentrated
in those things like Health Care
automotive technology engineering
technology things that have increasingly
concentrated the expense so again part
of the challenge of maintaining
affordability only possible because of
the support we've gotten from from the
legislature
can some of these courses be delivered
online because your students are local
students and so is that a possibility
although some of this stuff it's
Hands-On you've got to be there to to do
it
um and also can you speak back to I
think the page before has the age range
of you know the groups of age range has
that changed in the past 10 years or so
or is that still pretty much the current
age ranges of the students well if I can
come to those questions we want one at a
time
um
on the age range of the students there's
been some shift over time in the sense
that 12 years ago after the last Great
Recession was winding down was the peak
for adult Learners over the last 12
years about 2 million adults 25 and
older who were enrolled in
post-secondary education have
disappeared or I should say they've gone
back into the labor market no longer
enrolled in undergraduate programs but
we're still serving a population that
that's significantly a a typical not
just by age but more likely to be
working more likely to be a part-time
student and full-time employed or
otherwise a responsible family member
um and then the other question
ah online about 30 of our instruction is
currently online we're currently uh
working across the system seven colleges
to find ways to be more efficient in
delivering that and because again to
some degree there are things that we do
that are tailored to communities in
other cases there's a consistency and to
the extent that we can capitalize on
efficiency on things that don't really
distinguish needs among communities now
thank you Mr chair thank you Chancellor
for taking the questions I was looking
at your no cost low cost textbook
program and I want to you know commend
you for that because frankly in my
experience a lot of the textbooks
currently sold today are rather
questionable value proposition
um I just wanted to ask obviously you
are doing it in your system you are also
working with a lot of high schools on
other programs is this something that
you feel some of the high schools could
benefit from and would there be a way to
share with them the benefits of the
program to help them maybe you know
reduce the costs of the you know
education while maintaining the same
educational quality I I think that it's
becoming a broad Trend it certainly in
post-secondary education the open
education resources in terms of quality
in terms of learning are fine I don't
know enough about the uh the finances or
the mechanics of textbook purchasing in
the school district level but again the
quality of materials that are now
available for instruction at the college
level are our compelling value
proposition to not ask a student to
spend significant dollars for a textbook
that's out of date the next when the
next Edition is published thank you
you're welcome sir
in that same vein I I should mention
that one of the other areas that we're
interested in
not only online expands the concept of
classrooms but the ways in which people
learn it doesn't have to be delivered by
us people learn in a lot of different
environments and part of what we're
trying to do is figure out how to not
ask people to pay for and replicate
learning they can already document so I
spent seven years with Granite State
College and one of the key elements of
the work at Grand State College was
Prior learning assessment
it's not learning it's not college
credit for life experience and said
before in the School of Hard Knocks and
life teaches a lot of lessons they're
not all worth college credit but you can
demonstrate competencies in a lot of
areas you can work in a business where
you learn things that you would
otherwise learn in a classroom if you
can document that I don't want you to
pay for it to take a course to tell me
that you know it so figuring out ways
for us to build Bridges increasingly our
work is going to be in areas that are
outside of classrooms there are going to
be smaller you know shorter programs
more focused on career and Workforce
allow people who don't have a semester
or a year to get a degree but have two
or three months to get some core
training that they need and use that as
a building block that over time coupled
with work experience can grow into a
more portable degree
so we're trying to reinvent what we do
outside of classrooms more aligned with
employers needs more aligned with what
people as students and and you know
employees and family members need not
just what traditional classroom settings
allow
yeah thank you again
um are you partnering with learn
everywhere programs is there any
connection there I was surprised to
learn that Families First you know
friends forever all the s friends
forever offers the highest number of
courses of learn the learn everywhere
program then that's offered I was just
really surprised and a lot of this is
but to learn everywhere I wonder if it
dovetails in with what you're talking
about not in a branded way but but it's
the same philosophy that that students
can learn in a variety of environments
we don't need to control where students
learn and we don't need to replicate
what they can demonstrate that they
already know we do need to find some way
to document and validate that learning
so that it can be incorporated into a
degree but again for non-credit
credentials one of the barriers over
time has that has been the limits on
federal financial aid the primary source
of funding for for most student is
federal aid and it has certain limits on
what it's applicable to we're trying to
find ways to make education more
accessible in formats that may or may
not meet the federal government's
guidelines but are what students
actually need
and that learn everywhere concept is
I have a question
who was your
protagonist inside of high schools who
who's your cheerleader I mean it's very
complex what you're presenting to us and
if I'm a high school student there's got
to be somebody I can
a conduit to get to you I mean or are
you directly one-on-one with all the
students I I don't have enough bandwidth
for that but every one of our colleges
has a running start coordinator who's
regularly involved with the high schools
who's talking to principals who's
talking to guidance counselor who's
talking to teachers I think that our
best Advocates are actually teachers
who've been involved with us who know
what the benefits are to their students
parents of students who've gone through
running start who recognize the
opportunity
we've we've fostered Goodwill over time
by doing good work on behalf of New
Hampshire families and again it's not a
it's not a specific point of contact as
much as it says part of being the fabric
of a community our colleagues at each of
the campuses you know each has advisory
boards are well well engaged with
neighbors and a lot of this is going to
be Word of Mouth
foreign
probably helpful for this group to know
that the community college system of New
Hampshire has also been the hub for
apprenticeships in the state of New
Hampshire when I say that folks often
ask about plumbing and electricians and
interestingly they have their own sort
of channels for apprenticeships but we
have through the last six and seven
years now had a series of federal grants
to support apprenticeships aligned with
the state sector partner initiatives
anything from Hospitality to health care
we do a lot of work with employer
Partners throughout the state we've just
this past summer received an additional
five and a half million dollars through
apprenticeship building America grant
program will run for four years allows
us to set up Regional hubs throughout
the state again tailored to local needs
working with employers who see the
opportunity to help bring people into
their organizations with that Hands-On
learning experience complemented by the
education that we can offer the related
instruction that helps to grow the
critical thinking communication the
skills that allow somebody to develop
over time into leadership in an
organization
I I as I said it was good to have
director Reid with me
um Healthcare I mentioned earlier in the
context of an area of concentration
that's also increasingly expensive for
delivery but it's also increasingly
important for the state among the
figures that I'm most proud of since
2011 2012 that year we've prepared over
3 200 nurses for this state RNs in
addition to a 250 LPNs the LPN program
was one that you invested in three years
ago brought back through River Valley
the model that we've developed instead
of asking multiple colleges to create
the same program which is described an
expensive proposition River Valley
sought accreditation for the program now
partners with Lakes Region White
Mountains Manchester Nashua will be
delivering that program in five
communities throughout the state and by
the end of next year we'll probably see
about 1 100 graduates from that program
roughly half the state's annual need for
LPNs so relatively quick ramp up for
that program efficient delivery but
again just part of an illustration
anything from medical assistance lnas
the dental hygienists and dental
assistants that I mentioned earlier
phlebotomist middle medical lab
technicians radiologic technicians
radiation therapy technicians
occupational
Orthopedic text anyone on the front line
any of us who spend time in health care
is probably run into one of our
graduates Hands-On and the significant
part of the work that we do represents
about 30 different programs across the
state
yes thank you Mr chair
um I'm just wondering along the same
line of thought
um these programs that you're speaking
about the healthcare kind of Pathways
that you offer has enrollment for these
particular programs has it stayed steady
or just like continue to grow what are
you seeing so interestingly the most
stable enrollments we've had have been
in our health care programs there are a
lot of a lot of colleges and
universities in the world and are all
competing for students but they're not
as much competing for these students
because these programs are relatively
expensive to deliver so over time our
health care programs particularly
nursing have been among the most
consistent that we've seen graduating
typically about 230 to 240 nurses a year
for instance
other programs where the where the tide
has has abbed again business liberal
arts have have been programs that have
seen less demand in part because we've
we've taken care of that through dual
enrollment to some degree but again also
areas where a lot of college and
universities would love to serve those
students because that's a really cost
effect effective way to deliver
enrollment
thank you Mr chair just a quick
follow-up to the you know your remarks
about the nursing program and you know
the fact that we are subsidizing it
quite a bit
is it do you have any metrics on how
many of the people who graduate stay in
New Hampshire
and work in New Hampshire I know it's
hard to keep track of them after
graduation but what data do you have on
that so two two pieces of information
I'll focus on nurses and first overall
about 93 percent of our students are
from New Hampshire and I'll say that for
some of the students who are not and
anyone who's been in the Upper Valley
anyone who's been in the North Country
knows that the borders in Vermont and
Maine are kind of permeable and you know
you could be working for Dartmouth
Hitchcock and whether you live on the
Vermont side of the New Hampshire side
you're kind of part of that the the
workforce in terms of our nurses in
particular two-thirds of our graduates
are in their late 20s or older and those
typically are students who are part of a
community part of a family and they're
not the students who are graduating and
jumping on the road to travel so I I
can't say that none of them leave the
state and I can't say particularly in
the southern part of the state where
Massachusetts has a a wage premium that
I know is compelling for nurses but I
would say that that because the profile
of our students and where they are in
their lives I think that we do a good
job together of hanging on to our our
graduates thank you and by the way I'm
completely happy to you know subsidize
this for people who live in New
Hampshire or work in New Hampshire
either way I don't really you know but I
would just be a bit concerned about
subsidizing it for people who graduate
and then move out and don't work here so
you know I understand we don't control
that and it's not a huge concern but I
did want to better understand and I
think I have a good you know I'm I'm
very happy with what I heard thank you
thank you Mr cheer thank you
um
I don't know if it was last summer I
think was last summer that I went to
visit MCC and I had the privilege of
um viewing a program for students that
were being prepared to work with army
and Dean campus program
do you have a series of other programs
like that across the state and then I'm
just going to add on another question
are County nursing homes are desperate
for health workers I know in
Hillsborough County they have a a learn
to work program that they're actually
working are you partnering with them or
have they reached out to you at all I'm
just wondering in terms of your work
with the counties at all well on the
first one with army there's probably
nothing quite like Dean came in an army
anywhere else in the state but that
would be Dan Le Rochelle is a faculty
member at Manchester who's been working
we've signed a letter of support for a
grant to see if we can help build
capacity for Workforce because there's
going to be a need for technicians in
that industry and we're well positioned
to support that
we do have programs that that prepare
lnas and medical assistants as well we
don't have specific Partnerships with uh
with the counties but again that's an
opportunity and an opportunity to
leverage the investment that you make in
you know thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question what do you
figure it takes you to train a
full-fledged RN
and how how much of that program we had
three years how much does that affect uh
the money we gave uh to increase that uh
how much has that had an effect on that
I'm not sure I can fully answer the
question as I said we we know what it
costs per credit to deliver the
instruction part of the reason that
that's expensive is that it requires
clinical placement for those students
that the supervisory relationship it's
eight students per supervising faculty
member and the demand for academically
qualified nurses to actually work as
Educators rather than to return to
nursing you know it it's tough so those
things contribute to the to the expense
in terms of the LPN program where you
made a targeted investment the first
year that program launched there were 37
graduates there 53 this year we expect
that next year will be approaching 100
graduates in that program one of the
really nice things about that program is
that it was constructed it's a one-year
12-month one-year program but it's set
up in a way that a student who finishes
that program who then wants to pursue an
RN can stay right in stride and do that
so that a student who has that ambition
uh you know again it's it's a it's a an
effective way for a student to ramp up
thank you again
um can you speak to Partnerships or
collaboration with hospitals that are
hiring these nurses
well I I we've got a fairly extensive
list of our Partnerships
um
we as I said there's a clinical
requirement for all of these programs so
we've got Folks at CMC and Elliott we've
got folks in the Seacoast at Portsmouth
Regional and I I'm reluctant to start
naming which I've done because I'm going
to start leaving off but you go to you
go to North Country uh in in Berlin
you're going to find our students it
literally embedded in in just about
every every community and Health Care
setting so we that that's an integral
part of the relationship particularly
about do they provide you any financial
support
not not in a not in a direct uh
Financial way but I said the partnership
is essential it's mutually beneficial of
course but I I don't think that I can
point to a specific transaction
maybe 10 or 15 years ago a Consortium of
hospitals all contributed money over a
span of four or five years so that we
could build radiation technology and
radiologic technician programs at nhi
here in Concord that's the the only
campus that has those programs because
they're very Capital intensive so that
was launched directly with financial
contributions made by the Consortium of
hospitals because they you know needed
those graduates in their Workforce and
that we've sustained those programs even
after that initial kind of launch
commitment and it thank you
thank you the students paid that are in
the hospital did they paid for their
worker because their students are they
not paid
not paid for the instructional part of
the work that they're that the learning
part of the work they're doing there are
some students who are in fact already
employed by Health Care Providers and
also working on nursing degrees and
again one of the things about our
students they're finishing an associate
degree in nursing they'll they'll pursue
and take the NCLEX exam they'll be
licensed to practice they may then
continue for a bachelor's or a master's
or a doctorate nursing but at that point
they are on the clock they are being
paid I should mention by the way for
four years in a row the state with the
highest pass rate on that National exam
for associate degree prepared nurses New
Hampshire
we also do have some healthcare programs
that are offered through our
apprenticeship program and those are
explicitly earned while you learn models
where the individuals are hired as
employees in these in these hospitals
and Healthcare settings paid a wage for
their work they're taking at the same
time related classroom instruction and
as they progress through the program
they are in they earn higher wages when
so a couple of other areas that that we
haven't touched on each of our colleges
has a business train Training Center
this is typically that non-credit work
that I described earlier short-term
programs although not exclusively this
can include anything from coding boot
camps microelectronics boot camps
um
LNA programs programs that are outside
of the normal structure that uh you know
again federal financial aid and
classroom based that that are typically
shorter more focused more career
oriented
each of the colleges has one of those
centers to tailor programs to local
needs partnering with individual
employers industries that are are
you know well industries that have a
focus in that Community
um
the the other area that I'd like to
touch on in part of a request that we
made in our budget this year has to do
with child care if if housing is one
part of the challenge for Workforce
another part has been child care we
offer Child Care early childhood
education programs across the state
there's already a patchwork of Grant
programs to support participation our
observation based on our own experience
with our students is that we often see
students
progress part way through those programs
but then give up and part of it we think
is the complexity of that Patchwork we
think that if we could help simplify the
on the on-ramp the financial on-ramp to
those programs lessen the cost lessen
the burden of debt we can help people
get into that Workforce and stay in that
Workforce without the competing pressure
of repaying loans
um so we we have made up a focused
request in that area again we think it's
part of our mission as Educators but
part of our understanding of what our
communities need in order for employers
and and Workforce to thrive in New
Hampshire
thank you Mr chair thank you uh for
taking my question along the same line
of thought about this childhood Child
Care track that seems to be complex
could you
speak to the complexity that you were
mentioning and also you know why the
burden of expense is is you know
prohibiting some of these people from
you know finishing the full track sure
so part of it there's a grant program
it's not a criticism just a reality it's
administered by DHHS and it covers all
of certain courses 50 of other courses
and none of other courses and so student
has to figure out which courses they're
taking which are paid for how they come
up with the other half or the full
amount and our experiences that students
when they have to reach into their
pockets you know just get to the point
where it's harder to justify the expense
when in fact they know that the return
on that investment financially is not
going to be there
you have employers whether it's retail
or other industries that are offering
wages that are 50 100 more than someone
can earn even with a credential in child
care and the debt that they carry for
having paid for that our interest is in
removing some of the complexity of the
funding so someone can complete the
credential move through more
expeditiously be in a position where
they can begin to work and not have that
burden of debt knowing that the work
they do is valuable just isn't isn't
rewarded in the same way as other other
foreign
ergen had asked me if I thought we could
fill two hours and I I really wasn't
sure
um and having the chancellor not really
use the slide deck um presents a bit of
a challenge but what I did want to call
your attention to starting on slide 18
of the handout these are really just a
range over those three pages 18 19 and
20. of some of the companies that we
work with some of the types of it looks
um some of the the really the very broad
range of programming that we we provide
in partnership with companies so it
might be everything from very technical
skills in in Precision manufacturing to
um soft skills in terms of just being
prepared to be part of a Workforce or
leadership skills that helps someone to
move from an entry level position up
into a supervisory role these are all
across the state and they really span
um Industries
um again from very very technical
manufacturing to to child care and and
and Home Care Home Health Care
um and and these just about every
hospital and healthcare provider in the
state has been a partner with us at some
point
um we have some some very
um supportive Partnerships with entities
like the New Hampshire Automotive
Dealers Association that you're probably
familiar with that's a group that maybe
individually competes with one another
for Workforce and for customers but they
band together for
um
to support the workforce pipeline so the
auto dealers will provide scholarship
support to students going into programs
they will have recruiters go to high
schools and try to interest students in
the profession they provide us with
materials and equipment and curriculum
they sit on advisory boards and that's a
that's a model that is replicated to
varying extents through other programs
that we offer so nearly every degree
program that we offer across all of our
seven colleges has an Advisory board
made of Industry representatives and
this is one mechanism that really keeps
us tied to the trends within an industry
what are the what are the workforce
needs what are they seeing in terms of
technology and curricular needs so as
you as you kind of Imagine our network
of seven colleges imagine that net that
Network much more broadened and robust
through all of those industry Advisory
Board connections that really include
several hundred people in the state who
are providing us with input on what we
should be doing and how we should doing
it
yeah thank you do you have any
thank you we currently have about six
and a half million dollars in endowments
that have been uh gifted to the
community college system to individual
colleges or or to the system as a whole
um
modest
relatively speaking but generating about
a
about a half a million dollars a year in
scholarship support and other forms of
thank you this is not as much a question
as a comment on the program Spotlight
about the River Valley Community College
and the Department of Corrections
I did want to thank you for paying
attention to often underserved segment
of our population which you know
was in jail for certain reasons but once
they come out they do deserve a bit of a
hand to you know find a way to make a
living the right way and seriously I do
appreciate that you identify that as a
need and uh you know did what you could
to serve it do you have any you know
stats on how that improves outcomes
versus departments that don't offer this
in terms of you know showing the
thank you that program is is pretty new
so at this point we don't have outcome
metrics but that's something that we are
keeping an eye on in the future since
you mentioned the the spotlights if you
look at um slide 10 it's a partnership
Spotlight and this is a program where we
we recognize that the healthcare
Workforce really ought to be as diverse
as the individuals that that Workforce
serves and in this in this community in
Manchester there are people with the the
desire and really the aptitude and the
capacity to be to enter the healthcare
Workforce but maybe their language is a
barrier they're not English language
speakers so we are partnering
um
with a couple other institutions to
basically provide that language supports
as these students enter the healthcare
Workforce so it it allows people who are
again underserved but in a different way
to really enter the workforce in New
Hampshire in a skilled way and meeting a
high a high need professional demand
thank you uh last go-around there was a
lot of very long and tedious discussions
around educational cannibalism and
declining enrollments
um you know we're Dartmouth will
cannibalized from the University system
University system can begin to call and
so and and you're seeing you know these
programs moving down can you speak to
um whether you're seeing that or not or
was a lot of that discussion
um just more discussion well he yes but
I mean at one level that's true this
region in particular probably has 15 or
18 percent fewer high school graduates
than it did in 2005 2006 and we'll
probably have another 10 or 15 percent
fewer a decade out
so for institutions that are primarily
focused on Resident students you know
traditional age students 18 year old
high school graduates that that's a
declining population and the competition
is fierce and and there is
cannibalization but one of the things in
going back to the slide that was
highlighted earlier about the
demographics of the population
the premise that we have is that the the
demand for post-secondary education is
not getting smaller just because there
are fewer 18 year olds it's getting
different and it's going to be different
because
30 or 40 years ago you could finish
college whether it was two years or four
years and that education might see you
through a career
now
we have Industries I mean regenerative
medicine Whoever thought we'd be
fabricating tissue well Dean Cayman
figured that out but most people didn't
and you know again there are people who
are web developers and app developers 20
years ago
who knew what that was
so we don't know what 20 years from now
will be but we're pretty sure that their
educational programs that don't
currently exist that have to be built
and they're going to be people who are
currently in the workforce or just
starting in the workforce or not yet in
the workforce we're going to need
education that doesn't currently exist
we've got to position ourselves to grow
not contract and not compete over the
same 18 year old students
part of part of our issue or our
interest in creating efficiency for
online
is not just to conserve resources but to
be able to reallocate and invest in the
things that we don't currently do that
we know are going to be necessary so yes
the cannibalism happens and if your
primary need is a classroom building and
you've got a residence hall and a dining
hall and you've got to fill those or
your financial model falters our our
effort as I said earlier to reinvent
move more in the direction of those
Workforce programs those things that may
not be
I I hate to use the word lucrative but
things that are not currently aligned
with the way that the federal government
invests in post-secondary education
because the federal government hasn't
caught up with what the world actually
needs to do so we're trying to do more
of those kinds of things anticipating
one that it's what people actually need
what Employers in the state need and
eventually the federal government may
catch on as well
but we're we're trying to build capacity
for future the point that was made
earlier regarding folks who've been
incarcerated two of our campuses and
White Mountains already approved nhti in
the process of being approved for Second
Chance pale the ability for individuals
incarcerated in state facilities to
access federal financial aid working
with individuals in recovery working
with again people who change their
interests over time you know an industry
disappears an employer decides to leave
but sometimes your own interest in what
you want to do with your life changes to
help people who are not 18 and can't
take two years off to get into college
and sit in classrooms but who are 35 and
parents and who need to do it in the
stride of life that's where we're trying
to position ourselves because that's the
thank you I just want to say thank you
your nimbleness is unbelievable and I
think every time I go to River's Edge I
have an intern from one of your schools
but over the years and as I said to the
Chamber of Commerce in Manchester when
we had a gathering I think counting on
our community colleges is is what we
have to do in our four-year University
system as well but you're able to take a
need that a company has and develop a
program and I just think that's just
amazing and it's what the state of New
Hampshire needs because we're getting
old
um a lot of us I think we're the second
oldest state
um and we've got Maine and so New
England is getting older but we still
need those workers we're going to need a
lot of geriatric people that's for sure
but I want to thank you because I
watched your programs over the years and
I've just been so impressed and I have
to say running start is near and dear to
my heart
um just as a former assistant
superintendent and working with your
people there and what I've seen it grow
into and the number when I hear it on
the soccer field parents talking about
running start did you know about that
that's what's made a difference
to so many families so thank you because
I think you're doing so much thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh
I've asked this question before over the
years are we gonna are you gonna try to
award more four-year degrees I know I
know there's a the uh of course we had a
near miss last term and we want to get
away from that and I know you have I
believe you have the ability to offer a
four-year degree and I noticed that the
RN you'd almost have to have a four-year
program to uh to you know get a
registered or in up to speed
so
no
um our mission is is very focused and
adding one more layer of bachelor's
awarding institutions doesn't really
help it would contribute to the
cannibalism that was as asked about
earlier
there are neighboring states in Vermont
in Vermont Community College of Vermont
students do Allied pre-health program
through the community college and then
transfer to Vermont Technical College
pay three times as much as we charge per
credit 644 credit for their nursing
program for their dental hygiene program
to end up with a three-year bachelor's
degree
as much as anything else that's a
financial model to help that program be
financially solvent but it also creates
a cost barrier to students and
could could we do it I I imagine we can
but it would actually require that we
add additional faculty to offer
additional upper division courses for
students to complete bachelor's degrees
would probably be as inefficient as
anything that that I could imagine I'd
much rather find a different way to
solve the solvency for some of our our
costly programs and not create a layer
of of coursework Simply to subsidize
what we know is expensive uh my interest
if we're going to grow is that we grow
in the direction of those Workforce
credentials that we grow in the
direction of those shorter term programs
that people are going to need over 40 or
50 years of working life and learning
life to be able to stay you know engaged
in in a changing economy in a changing
Workforce in the state
once again I have to add something up
just because I had when I was at I was a
dean of school of education at Southern
New Hampshire University and we had
wonderful Partnerships with the school
so that your students would finish their
two years and then they'd go on to
finish a four-year degree so you made
that possible and allowable which I
thought was very very flexible and from
what I understand in the nursing program
yes and in fact the students that we
graduate from our nursing programs
become our ends after a two-year nursing
program
a student can go to a four-year
bachelor's degree program and graduate
and become an RN same job it's just that
our our nursing our in degree is more
kind of focused on the nursing aspects
the the more Health Care aspects and and
not all of those sort of general
education courses that are built into
the four-year degree so many of our
students will graduate after the
two-year Nursing degree go into the
workforce as an RN and simultaneously
work toward a Bachelor of Science but
that
that does that it's not a different job
that they do it's not a different level
of nursing it's still the RN so it's a
an efficient way for someone to get into
the workforce as an RN sooner than if
they were to pursue a four-year path
and thank you Mr chair this is a comment
about the previous question
um I used to teach for about 10 years I
was a Microsoft certified trainer
certified novel instructor so I would
have fit somewhere in your business type
classes in those business centers and
I think that's an amazingly important
niche in general because there are a lot
of places that will give you a generic
four-year degree the challenge that
people have is that oh that's all nice
and good you graduate high school you
get a general purpose degree now what
there are all those adjustments and
career changes and things that you need
to do so that's a huge unmet need and
seriously I think that you are doing
very well to focus on those types of
programs because I think that's where we
clearly have a need plus those programs
have to be addressed to the local needs
of our communities which differ from you
know a different state or even if you go
100 miles you know in New Hampshire
you'll find very different needs for
education so that's why it's so
important to look at the local stuff and
deliver the programs that are needed for
the local residents for the local
employers and I'm very happy that you
are so focused on that thank you
one example I'd like I hope you're aware
of is um Nashua Community College is in
a region that has a lot of small and
medium-sized manufacturers and the
college recently created
boot camps eight-week training programs
encoding and microelectronics and the
relationship with the Employers in the
region particularly with vae systems is
very strong and those graduates go on
the graduates of those very short term
very focused very efficient boot camps
go on to get excellent jobs in in
technology in for our New Hampshire
employers and I sit on the board of swim
the State Workforce Innovation board and
we hear at every meeting we hear a
series of success stories and the number
of students who have come out of at-risk
situations a very um very kind of
entry-level jobs in
restaurants or retail who go through a
coding boot camp and end up a tech a
high-tech worker in the state that's
really inspiring and I see that a lot
and that's I think that gets to the that
next that next chance Beyond sort of the
generic degree that you were talking
about
I'm I'm kind of Blown Away here I didn't
realize that you could get an RN
certification in two years I mean I'm my
mind's blown what so that sounds to me
like that that should be a lead product
you know because our ends make pretty
good you know return on that invest
especially with you
to go out and have a professional degree
quote professional degree in two years
that's the that's unbelievable
and and all of our nursing programs are
um are very high demand programs we
typically have more applicants than we
can accept
um and the rigorous those are very
difficult programs they're by no means
easy
um
hospitals will
um typically desire a mix of RNs some
who are associated degree trained and
some who are bachelor's degree trained
which which for us just provides it just
means there's an opportunity for our
students to to start with us get a
foothold in the profession and then and
then earn the bachelor's degree if they
wish at some point after they're kind of
past that first
now these guys are good huh
um somewhere in here there's a reference
to
um your Workforce and providing is this
faculty can you speak to your your
faculty needs uh there was some mention
about attrition people retiring
um your ability to hire The Faculty that
you need well twofold and part part of
it is our enrollment has shifted we have
seen our full-time faculty roles to
climb by about 30 percent over the last
decade and part of that just Resource
Management in areas that are high demand
like nursing as I described earlier
somebody who's qualified to teach nurses
is also qualified to work as a nurse and
compensation is is highly competitive
we're fortunate to have nursing faculty
and and other practitioners whether it's
in engineering Technologies Automotive
who really value the role they play as
Educators knowing that they're
contributing Downstream to the Next
Generation in those workforces but those
are the places where we do find some
competitive pressure
and again because there are clinical
ratios that have to be maintained for
faculty to students and it is one of the
limiting factors in how much these
programs can can grow
I if if I might come back representing
Petra has the question earlier about
whether we had an interest in four-year
programs I just want to comment to the
RN program in particular about eight or
nine years ago an RN to BSN program a
partnership with Granite State College
within the university system was created
where the community college system
offers the first three years of the
degree the fourth year offered by
Granite State College but at the
community college system tuition rate
for me that's a model of how you balance
access and affordability without getting
into the four-year territory last year
with the passage of HB 1530 the part the
pathways bill from from the house part
of the language in there was to optimize
the you the affordability and utility of
the community college system we took
that to mean that it's not just two plus
two it's how much education can we
appropriately deliver toward that
four-year degree that a student's
looking for in this may be the Genesis
of more three plus one programs or two
and a half one and a half but again
trying to find things that make the most
sense for students that make the most
sense for affordability and access to
support Student Success and the state's
Workforce
good thank you
well I I actually I'm a product of uh
I guess it's Lake Region Lakes Region
now and I found it very helpful
the professor was a retired engineer
that got into
teaching because he loved teaching and
and he taught physics and like trig
things things like that and it was very
helpful to see his background and to put
it into the classroom where
uh a lot of times you get just Theory
and that's not what you want to be
especially and it helped me you know
later on because I ended up going back
in the Air Force and uh
probably on what I'd learned at the VOC
Tech
hmm
earlier this morning I was downstairs at
a bill that has to do with First
Responders
and when I was doing some internal
preparation for that bill I spoke to the
heads of our criminal justice department
at nhgi who his career was in
um Municipal Police and Major Crimes the
head of our paramedic emergency medicine
program who as we spoke we had one one
meeting where he was sitting in an
ambulance
um being ready ready to go on on a call
because he was in the profession and the
head of our fire science program who
used to work at the New Hampshire fire
academy so we have such wealth in our
faculty of of Industry experience that
really enhances what the students
learned and how they learn and how they
I want to backtrack
we were talking about uh the daycare
a program for daycare
managers owners what what am I going to
learn
to go a daycare curriculum so in this
case we're really talking about Early
Childhood Educators is I you know I want
to be clear that part part of the value
isn't just that somebody looking after
the kids it's somebody who's going to
help stimulate their learning because
that's a that's a critical age for you
know the mind to flourish so we're
trying to prepare Educators to work with
that population to help those children
really thrive in that environment not
have parents worried that children are
being you know just warehoused or or or
simply left to you know be attended to
but not really nurtured so this is
really more education but for somebody
who's interested in staying in the
profession to grow into a management
role leadership role in that setting you
know is certainly part of a curriculum
that we can deliver
but isn't it true that in order to start
a daycare you have to have an education
degree in education
or be a teacher or what I'm not I'm not
familiar what the requirements are I
just asking a question well I and I I
don't want to get into the what would it
take to start the daycare but in terms
of the Educators role in that daycare
setting you're looking for somebody
who's academically qualified has the
experience and the knowledge to Foster
learning in that population understands
how to look after the well-being of that
child but if you also wanted to grow
into a management track if you will to
to over time become an organizational
leader in that environment beyond the
educational piece you know again we
could build a management certificate
layer to that or somebody could pursue a
business degree on top of it but we're
starting with the fundamental issue of
how do you nurture uh children okay so
that's the primary focus of the of the
education is early childhood development
exactly okay thank you
foreign
thank you I know this is a more of a
system overview but I'll take the
opportunity to be a little more specific
and ask you about the White Mountains
branch in North Conway and the last time
I visited there it was there was I
believe it's a Health Care lab or
a Veterinary lab I'm yeah but
um what what kind of students are going
in there and and uh the local students
taking advantage of having that Branch
there uh I'll be honest to say
relatively limited engagement up there
um enrollment has been modest at best
and
White Mountains is trying to figure out
is there a different strategy for
engaging in that community
well thank you
no I you know I I again when Granite
State College was in that location the
same issue and part of it is that
um the the distance more and more
students were opting for online learning
as opposed to showing up in classroom
settings and it it creates a challenge
or operationally because the enrollments
you know begin to to dwindle hmm
go ahead
I was I was just going to sort of wrap
up
um but if you have a question well I was
going to ask you this is an aside
we're going to hear the governor's
budget next week
how did your meetings go with the with
the governor
uh yeah I I thought it was a
constructive conversation I shared with
him as I shared with this group our
focus on affordability access creating
Pathways for students trying to help
families you know the affordability is
is certainly for students with greatest
need but it's also a pathway for
students and families in the middle
class for whom federal aid is not going
to be there and we we talked about that
as an opportunity
um I I felt that the governor listened
and and and was thoughtful in questions
to go along with that question thank you
um I've been reading that the business
associations have been encouraging
better funding for our community
colleges and higher ed
institutions
hopefully that will play into a reality
I think this would be a good time to
I know I for one know that it's so
important to have you do what you do and
you need the resources to carry those
out so hopefully with the voices of the
business Community it will help to add
to what he has
um dedicated and hopefully we'll
consider that as well I think we did a
good job last time and hopefully we'll
do better this time
if there are other questions and
certainly if there are please please ask
us but I I just wanted to point out at
the very end of our slide deck are a few
slides of pictures and if a picture is
worth a thousand words I encourage you
to look at these but even more I
encourage you to come and visit our
campuses you can reach out to the
chancellor or to me and we will be more
than happy to arrange a visit to any of
our colleges that you might like to see
whether it's one in your region or one
that has a program that's of interest to
you and we would love to to host you
um at our schools one of the slides has
pictures of um what looks like a lot of
HVAC equipment and this is a fairly new
bill to get Manchester Community College
that does in fact has our HVAC program
and the building itself is a lab as you
can see from the pictures it was
constructed to be a learning environment
in and of itself not just made of
classrooms and Labs but but made to be
classrooms and labs and that's the type
of of Hands-On approach that we try very
hard to incorporate into in all of our
curriculum where where it makes sense so
we really look forward to the
opportunity to show you
I'd offered just one additional thought
that we haven't touched on
we serve students we serve employers the
one employer in this state that I'm most
covered as a partner is the state of New
Hampshire
there's not an industry in this state
that the state doesn't State as an
employer doesn't touch
you know we're anywhere from we talked
about health care but we're anywhere
from Automotive to welding got nothing
with Z at this point but anywhere from a
to W but again Health Care education
Addiction Counseling you you look at the
range of resources we have available
throughout the state and if there's a
way in which we can be a better partner
to the state as an employer help serve
the state to help serve the state
citizens
I don't want us to miss that opportunity
so as you continue to speak with other
agencies and think about problems the
state's trying to solve if the workforce
if there's a way for us to impact that
Workforce helpfully I hope that that
you'll be helping you know direct folks
to ours and see if we can't build better
one more thank you
um
what is what was you mentioned earlier
what's a four pill
well
federal government and Pell Grant is the
primary Grant available to students with
need and full pound this year was
6895 dollars next year it's currently
slated to be 7
395 dollars if a student has a zero
effective family contribution there's an
Arcane formula behind the behind the
curtain that gets you there some
students have a zero EFC some students
it's two thousand or three thousand
whatever happens to be for a student
who's got a full pill next year in
theory we can help that student cover
all their direct expenses for the
student who still needs to find that two
or three thousand dollars the federal
government's figuring out that you can
find two or three thousand dollars in
your pocket I I've never met a family
that had the same understanding as the
federal government about what was in
their pocket so that that's what we're
trying to bridge because there's a lot
of students who have partial Pell Grant
or just misspell completely and we're
trying to help figure out how to how to
get that student through
but again the running start dual
enrollment the things that we can help
with your assistance uh while they're
still in high school goes a long way to
that
so just a very quick follow-up I'm
assuming that determining that
eligibility is where the lovable FAFSA
application comes in
just for the record while we never
really had to file it because we knew we
were not gonna qualify I will say that's
one of the most painful forms to fill in
anybody's life and it's a perfect
example of why honestly the federal
government
misunderstands you know what people can
give them it's it's it's ridiculous
amounts of information so thank you
thank you my apology to my colleague who
put so much effort into the materials
that I then did not make great use of
but thank you for your patience so I
will just let the committee know that we
do tentatively have the community
college system coming back on the 16th
to discuss the governor's recommended
budget so we will see them next week on
Thursday and I think Shannon did
reference a bill relative to
um dual and concurrent enrollment we may
see that bill referred to us from the
house floor this coming Tuesday the
house education exec that as well as the
math communities uh program so it's
House Bill 419 and House Bill 420. 419
is the math learning communities bill
which is a program we used to do that is
a partnership with the high schools
where we are helping to develop a math
curriculum that will enable high school
students to leave High School ready for
college math which has been a huge gap
and then 420 is to build that ex expands
the Dual and concurrent enrollment
program
okay
uh it's
one of the things you just touched on
and that we've been having a problem in
the past and that's kids going starting
college and not being not having the
skills to do the math and they have to
have remedial are we still in that uh
in that problem
we we don't we don't deliver remedial
math at this point but we do have and
some of our colleges offer a
co-requisite remediation from if you
will it's a course where the additional
support is built directly into the class
the old model of Developmental math a
student would take a course that didn't
actually qualify for college credit for
a lot of students that was just a dead
end so the strategies that have been
involving in the last decade have really
been more focused on figuring out what a
student needs to be successful rather
than putting them in a in a course that
yeah and you look at the Statewide
assessment and you look at the
performance of 11th graders in reaching
proficiency it shouldn't be surprising
we've got a fair number of students who
reach College where math is not the
strength that it you know the foundation
okay one o'clock
Apple time
the floor is yours
why is it pointing to me
my wife's blood sugar
oh God
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee
um for the record my name is Kathy
provencher I serve as the chief
administrative officer and the vice
Chancellor of Finance for our state's
University system
interim Chancellor and UNH president Jim
Dean sends his regrets he expected to be
here but is unable to I believe we are
scheduled to be back with you next
Thursday morning and president Dean will
be joining me when we really dive into
our budget request Mickey had mentioned
this is really an orientation provide
some information to you about the
university system answer any questions
and that could be helpful even for next
week if there aren't any questions I can
answer today we can bring the answers
next week so I have a few slides to go
through I really again this is more of
an orientation so the university system
is UNH
um and R1 research institution
University
land C and space Grant Institution
Keene State College over in the
Monadnock region and Plymouth State
obviously in Plymouth
and those and I'll talk a little bit at
the end about Granite State College is
being merged into the University of New
Hampshire actually Mark Rubinstein
was the president of Granite State
College and when he left to become
Chancellor of the community college
system our board decided that was an
opportunity to maybe merge the colleges
no need for another president and so
Granite State College is now part of a
college under the University of New
Hampshire
so we have about 22 000 students
most of them full-time
about half of our student population are
New Hampshire residents and half are
non-residents
and I'll talk a little bit more about
that
um as we as we spend some time together
today and next week
so the first slide is really just to
give you an idea of our governance
structure I'm on it's page two
so we have a very active 28-member board
there are represented the Senate
President has a designee senator Jim
Gray the speaker of the house has a
designee representative Rick Ladd we
have 10 gubernatorial seats um confirmed
by the governor and Council and a number
of ex-officios Commissioner of Education
Commissioner of Agriculture our
University presidents alumni and
students make up our board
so on on page three I really want to
make the point that the university
system is really a driver of Workforce
just as you heard from the community
college system I'm sure this morning
about 2 000 of our graduates entered the
New Hampshire Workforce every year that
number 18 800 we started tracking
um with the Department of Employment
Security back in 2012 trying to match
our graduates and their where they're
working
not specifically the place but the data
if they're working in New Hampshire and
so about 2 000 of our graduates joined
the workforce every year and that's a
big number I mean when you think about
it with half of our students residents
and half non-residents
that's another in my grader of young
Talent into the state and we need to do
our best to try to keep them here
we also have Partnerships with over 2
000 employers businesses across New
Hampshire
through internships apprenticeships and
actually part of our budget request is
additional funding to really ramp that
you know the statute requires that we be
a well-coordinated system
and for the most part we are we can
always do better
um but we are really with the challenges
I'm going to talk a little bit about
that in in a moment but with the
challenges we've been planning
it was actually just before the pandemic
we knew we were going to have to bring
our cost structure down because there
are fewer students we have demographic
challenges we have
intense competition around the region
and so we embarked on this
very significant effort to drive our
costs down
reduce employee head count
really
um make a robust shared services
function so that Plymouth keen and UNH
can share in common business practices
that reduces risk and reduces cost and
so between 2019 and 2022
we drove our cost structure down about
50 million dollars
now inflation hasn't helped that
but but the when we look at the
Apples to Apples we drove our cost
structure down about 50 million dollars
between 2019 2022 and it was recognized
by Moody's Moody's the credit rating
agency
um in in November
we were
on negative outlook actually the entire
higher education industry is on negative
outlook and Moody's changed our negative
outlook to stable back in November when
we went through an annual surveillance
um primarily because we are
developing strategies
implementing and executing on our plans
to make sure we're prepared for the
headwinds that are
coming our way
so on slide do you have an idea of what
your head count reduction was
it was
um representative it was through a uh
voluntary separation plan
480 employees took that voluntary
separation 480
faculty and staff combined took that
so on Slide Five
this is really just to give you an idea
of what our Revenue sources are where
the revenues come from that support the
operations of the University system
so you can see in the light blue most of
our funding comes from tuition
now I'll also point out that this
pie chart is gross revenue before
financial aid that we offer and when
it's a sizable amount of financial aid
yeah hey that's good that's good intense
thank you thank you Mr chairman thank
you for being here
uh
your endowment no you I've seen the
green part on the chart gifts
Investments what what is your endowment
worth and how much do you roll into your
students for tuition and whatever so the
the
um
representative if I could
next Thursday let me bring a whole bunch
of information on the endowment because
we have restricted and we have
unrestricted we also have
um
investment income
that supports campus operations it's not
huge but it's meaningful so let me bring
back some more like how many
scholarships we issue you know some of
the restricted endowment goes to
restricted scholarships then we have
unrestricted
that support unrestricted scholarships
you know they uh an endowment could
support a faculty chair something like
that so if if okay with you let me
really drill into that and bring some
detailed information
um when we present the budget next week
yeah they've taken my question um in
terms of you said that you reduced your
Workforce by over 400 people
so you have to have a ratio of full-time
profession teaching faculty to your
adjuncts
um have you been able to maintain that
by your um so editors so yes
actually we're go Keane just went
through accreditation and UNH is
starting now so the answer is yes
again this this is good so it helps me
know what to bring back next week I can
also tell you that while 480 employees
took that separation plan we knew we
were going to have to refill some of
those that's a huge
number of our Workforce so our plan was
that we would refill
about a third
of that number now I will say
they haven't been refilled necessarily
positioned for position right because we
evaluate what's the need now what's the
need in the future
so but let me let me get some detail on
are you done are you okay yes um yeah
along the same lines can you get a sense
of
um how many faculty are included in the
480 as opposed to the staff and where
foreign
I guess part of that also then would be
how many full-time positions
and or part-time positions are you
anticipating
because if you had if we talked about
head count right now you're understaffed
by some number like 160.
um no I would not say we're understaffed
we're trying to right size
knowing
that we have fewer students
that that
and I'm going to talk about that in a
bit about the demographics and the
competition so we're trying to right
size so I would not say we're
understaffed well I'm just saying you
said 480 took a retirement and about a
third you're going to re repopulate
about a third of that oh and we have
been with that program was in June of 20
one I think you had to separate by June
of 21. so we have been refilling
some of those positions since June of
21.
this is good
um so again so the the pie chart on
Slide Five shows you where our Revenue
comes from I mentioned
um
that UNH is an R1 research Institution
they're generating about 250 million
dollars a year
in in Grants and doing some really
remarkable research so that that's
become quite a big Enterprise at UNH
um
yes about seven percent comes from gifts
and Investments
and then the maroon is was called
auxiliary it's pretty much room and
board
and then just shy of eight percent of
our total revenues come from the state
this is a history of where our funding
levels have been from the state the
state operating support
the State dollars
subsidize in-state tuition our in-state
tuition
is about half of our out-of-state
tuition and so those State dollars
for the most part subsidize that
in-state tuition there's also so of the
88.5 million dollars that we've received
each year of this biennium about 13 14
million dollars goes to fund statutory
programs so there are programs in
statute Cooperative Extension
the agricultural experiment station and
so those statutory programs are
partially funded by the State
appropriation as well
I'll talk and
quick question if I may uh how much is
agricultural Now versus because this
used to be cow College
matter of fact it changed its name in
1923.
well I'm sorry agricultural portion
because that's that's where it has its
roots and
to see the difference between what would
what was you know it's evolving out of
the agriculture right world are are you
is your question about how many students
oh so we so we have so the Thompson
school which used to be a two-year
school is I don't I don't think there's
much activity there at all but there's a
college of Life Sciences and agriculture
colsa
that's a big college it's again it's
life sciences and agriculture
um I can get a breakdown if that will be
helpful of maybe the number of students
it's
now now I will tell you the College of
life science and agriculture of colsa is
I mean that's where our
we're in the middle of a very
significant
um Capital project
for our life sciences programs so the
College of Life Sciences and agriculture
is a very active College even though
everyone in in that school isn't
necessarily
um
working on anything related to
agriculture do am I making sense
I I understand your question well I
understand your question and let me see
what I can
great
um on slide six
I can tell you that our state support
has been flat since 2021 we are still 11
below the levels we were in 2011.
and um you'll hear a lot more detail on
this next week but in our budget request
for 24 and 25 we're seeking to get back
to that 2011 level seeking to get back
on slide seven
um you know it's important to talk about
Student Success because that's
that's our business right
um
helping our students succeed we have and
the six-year graduation rate that is in
it's called ipeds it's a federal
data
um repository and they use a six-year
graduation rate
we have the the university system has
the highest
six-year graduation rate of of any
public in New England and we're pretty
proud of that it's important to
um as best we can help students graduate
and graduate timely we also have one of
the lowest student loan default rates in
the country
and what that tells us is because we
also know our students carry a high debt
load
because we have the highest in-state
tuition or one of the highest in-state
tuitions in the country because we have
low State support
but what this tells us is our students
are employed they're able to pay their
loans off and where I think that's a a
significant metric for us that we have
one of the lowest student loan default
on slide eight
the um we've held tuition flat in-state
tuition flat for the last five years
while at the same time
awarding significantly more financial
aid
what that means is on average our New
Hampshire students are actually paying
less than they were five years ago if
your tuition's flat and your financial
aid is increasing
your your total bill what you're paying
is on the decrease
and um about five years ago
um we rolled out a program we called the
granite guarantee
any
Pell eligible New Hampshire student
attends one of our schools free tuition
now it's a last dollar scholarship
when when I say that I mean so you have
a Pell Grant is a Federal grant for
needy students financially needy
students and so if you're eligible for
the Pell Grant
we'll make sure that the rest of your
tuition
is covered not room and board we don't
cover room and board
it's really part of our public mission
our mission is providing affordable
access
to our students
who who want to attend our institutions
and that's part of the reason that our
financial aid has been growing as well
with the granted guarantee
so I've been talking about
um
what I consider good news
that our students are successful and
that we're trying to get our arms around
our costs and prepare for the future and
now I want to share with you some of the
not so good news we have some real
challenges and it is not isolated
yeah thank you could just go back to the
pal is are these full Pell Grants or do
you do anything with partial full grants
so whatever poll Grant they have you'll
cover the extra cost whether it's a full
pill or a partial pile correct
um
but they may help other Aid as well
right they could have a merit
scholarship they could be needy and have
a merit scholarship right and then
whatever the
Delta is the leftover we'll cover that
but no you don't have to be full pel
eligible partial Pell eligible students
also
enjoy the benefit of the Granite
guarantee
so on slide nine
um
higher education especially in the
Northeast
significant challenges
and those challenges are caused by
um the number of
K-12 students I have a chart on it in a
little bit is shrinking
all over the Northeast and while we have
students that come from around the
country and from around the world the
vast majority of our students that come
from out of state come from New England
so all of the New England states are
experiencing similar things and all
trying to compete for the same student
so we have changing demographics
intense competition and limited State
support
on slide 10 I don't um for those of you
that have been on division two this is
not any news to you New Hampshire has
the lowest funding of higher public
higher education in the country of any
state
so but on on slot and that again that
impacts in-state tuition which then
impacts We Believe
students decisions whether they stay
here to go to school or leave
so on slide 11 again I'm sure this is
not news to you the K-12 enrollment has
continued to decline which means the
pipeline into higher education also
shrinks
again the orange states that means
Public School enrollment is shrinking
the Northeast is shrinking everywhere
New Hampshire is shrinking more than
on slide 13. so what this does is it
causes
states around us to really everyone's
experiencing this so everyone's
competing for the same student so the
University of Maine
oh I want to say this has been maybe
four years ago
the University of Maine system will
offer in-state tuition to any student
who comes from New England New York New
Jersey and you can see the Billboards up
and down
95.
all the way to New Jersey
they're trying to get students to come
to Maine as so they have a pipeline for
their Workforce
and they're funding that
SUNY the State University system of New
I didn't mean to stop you in the middle
of that but
I hear what you're saying about their
strategy I would appreciate if you'd
share any data that you may have with us
on whether that strategy is working or
if it's too early to tell or what is the
you know income because intent is one
thing outcome is another and I'd like to
have as much information as possible on
both again you may not have it now but
you know if any data is available thank
you
great
um soon the State University system of
New York just launched uh big campaign
we're told a hundred million dollar
campaign and they're pushing through
Billboards social media well here you
can see this one
this this comes up on one of my
co-workers
feeds on I don't really do social media
but whatever she go to the State
University of New York for the in-state
tuition at unh
and there there is um actually
oh Tom took the picture there is
actually I think it's out on the
Spalding Turnpike
Billboards that are perpendicular to one
another one of them is Humane and the
other one is Sunni
so the competition is intense just I'm
just trying to make the point it's
another challenge that we're working
through
[Laughter]
um
slide 14 is really
State support and state partnership is
absolutely critical
we have we are seeking I mentioned
earlier
um we have requested
um an increase back to 2011 levels
I will tell and we'll get into a lot
more detail next week about this
um
but that increase primarily focused on
Plymouth and Keene
there is a piece that we're seeking
additional funding for Cooperative
Extension in the second year of the
biennium Cooperative Extension
is really remark it has remarkable reach
all over the granite state
and
um
can use the research that's done at UNH
to really take education programs out to
communities on Mental Health on
nutrition again we'll talk more about
that next week but the the bulk of the
additional request is for Plymouth and
Keene Plymouth and Keen
um
you're well aware are in regions of our
state that they serve as economic
anchors and real
pipelines into Workforce in regions that
need that pipeline
and a number of years ago UNH invested
in a program for its career and
Professional Services
office
they have more internships posted from
businesses than they have students
Plymouth and Keene need
the support to help them
develop these internship programs small
business another thing about internships
small businesses need more support it's
more difficult for small business to set
up an internship
than a than a large business and and we
can help with that but we need support
we need more State support
um
to to
increase those internships the other
thing with Plymouth and Keen I mentioned
the the financial aid
we're providing a lot of financial aid
and it is it is impacting specifically
Plymouth and Keene and we want to be
able to maintain
the level of financial aid that our
students need to be successful on our
smaller campuses smaller Regional you've
probably seen it in the media smaller
Regional campuses across the region
need more support than the flagship
um and and again president Dean will be
here interim Chancellor and president
Dean will be here next week and can can
talk a little bit more about that but
that's that's what our request is aimed
at we have the three percent
uh efficiency budget that would take the
88 and a half to 91.2 in each year and
then we've asked for an additional four
million dollars in the first year of the
biennium and 13 million dollars in the
second year of the biennium for
financial aid to support businesses
Cooperative Extension
thank you can you give examples of some
of the internships at these two two
campuses
at Plymouth and Keene uh yeah you know
where what are the internship
internships asking for What fields
so so
um Keen has a specific relationship with
um Bae actually
um I don't know if you saw last week we
had a there was a Business Roundtable
that was held at UNH Manchester with our
three presidents and
um some business leaders around the
state and um which I'm his last name is
escaping me he attended uh from Bae so
that's that's one there's also um
um
Advanced manufacturing and Optics
over in
um the Monadnock region that's been a
pipeline right now about 200 students at
Keene have internships the president
would like to see that to be 700 every
student should have at least one
internship the other thing that I we
believe that
that the benefit not only the businesses
a student is twice as likely to stay and
work in New Hampshire if they've been ha
if they've had an internship it's also
um a reason to come to Keene and
Plymouth
if you can get an intern if you know you
can get an internship
it's a reason to
um
a lot of the work at Plymouth is very
interesting it's not a specific
internship the president president Berks
at Plymouth has changed the curriculum
at Plymouth so it's he calls it a
cluster model but it's students that
major in different areas get together
and work on projects in businesses and
in communities in Lake Region North
Country actually they just this was also
in the media
I think there were about 10 students
from different disciplines marketing
accounting they worked with um
the new owner of or the owner of the
Gorham paper mill
on ways they brought a whole you'd think
of a consulting firm did it
um on ways that they can use excess land
related to that paper mill that isn't
going to be used and is
um needs to be cleaned up anyway my
point is
will participate in at least one of
these projects
business community non-profits and it's
it's a disa interdisciplinary it sounds
very academic but various students from
various Majors working on a project
together and and president Burks would
really like to expand that and he
follow-up thank you
um so if you can just go back a little
because I think you said that you have
more internships available at UNH at UNH
not if the other ones because okay thank
just a follow-up I actually did go up
there on Monday morning for the
legislative breakfast you know the
Plymouth State and uh you know I'm a
freshman I gotta go everywhere because I
have a lot to learn and it was actually
very educational very informational it
there was a lot of insight into you know
and you know they had panels with people
talking about their experiences and
overall I think it's a very Innovative
model it's risk when you tweak with the
traditional departments and whatnot but
you know if you want rewards sometimes
you have to take risks and I just wanted
to you know commend them and you know
make sure that I'm on the public record
is expressing my you know appreciation
of the work that went into preparing
that it was really good very helpful and
you know I hope those Innovations pay
off that's great thank you very much
representative
thank you Mr chair
um high red has gotten a lot of federal
money
um as a result of covert how have you
how is the University system been able
to leverage that in support of students
in the University campus
so the federal money that we received
for the most part offset our coveted
costs
I mean we incurred I have that in
another presentation your law says you
mean the losses oh yes
tens of millions of just the refunds
that we provided to students when we had
to close campus that was like 40 million
dollars so
um
does everyone I'm sorry does everyone
know Tom Cronin I think I've had a
chance to meet some of you here and
there uh but not everyone yet so Tom
Cronin the assistant vice president for
public affairs uh with UNH and work
closely with Kathy and our colleagues
across the system on her work up here so
I see various folks in other committees
just had to spend some time upstairs in
election law so sorry for being I was
just gonna say you can identify he had
to be in two two committee hearings at
once so
um
for almost all of the coveted costs that
we've incurred
the testing the mass you probably also
know UNH stood up its own lab
um
now there was
I know the acronym is herf h-e-e-r-f
those federal dollars flow directly to
our students pursuant to federal law
and
almost all of our students you're the
only requirement for those dollars was
you had to be have been impacted by
covet so the way we set it up pretty
much all of our students got federal
dollars
um
but for the most part
all of the federal dollars we we
received offset the the losses and the
costs that we incurred
to make sure our students and faculty
were were safe
foreign
just wanted to thank you for refunding
tuition to students who were impacted by
kovid and couldn't get their education
that they had paid for because very
bluntly my kid graduated Rensselaer
Polytech and we did not get one red sent
back when they were kicked off campus
and not allowed to return and not allow
not given any I mean it was a very
different treatment and I'm very very
happy that uh UNH did the right thing
and so many other places didn't and I'm
you know I I just you know as a
frustrated parent from the other side
I'm glad that you treated our parents
and students the right way thank you
well thank you and we thought it was
important let me clarify
we did not refund tuition because we
kept online learning but we refunded
all prorated all room bored all of that
from the day we had to send our students
home
so what happened to the support staff
that
that supported you know like food
service and whatever I mean they when
you had to send them home too I mean
it's yes there were Federal programs
though that helped with that
um
we did we didn't lay anyone off there
was another piece of a federal program
that the paycheck protection
so
um there were federal dollars that
helped with that but yes
those folks that have direct
care if you will
that's right we
they didn't work for a bit
that was the spring of 2020
and I can't remember did we bring our
students back in the fall of 20 around
and fall again yeah restricted
programming but people were on campus
right and I mean it was those those
folks who really did yeoman's work ever
since on trying to make that work in a
very difficult environment because we
heard from students students who wanted
to be back and we did everything we
could to bring them back even though it
took a little while to get programming
back to what you're seeing this semester
but
there are just a couple of
um appendices slides that I want to make
you aware of one has to do with that
Granite State merger
um
that that is more work than one might
think because we're taking a separately
accredited college
and merging it into another College
um but it it's on track after June of
anyone who graduates
from Grant State College with their
degree will say the University of New
Hampshire
and then on slide 17 I it's important to
note we have a very good
partnership and working relationship
with the community college system
I meet with Mark Rubinstein every other
week House Bill 1530 which was signed
into law last session requires us to
partner to have at least the 30 top
programs
have a seamless pathway for students who
go to any community college to transfer
in to one of our schools
um so we're we're working on that and
and a lot of other just maybe administer
I'd call them administrative
Partnerships procurement Partnerships
contracts that we're working on together
um so that's that's become a
a really good
partnership relationship with the
thank you
is nishack the accreditation
that for this area
okay I
have you seen a change
um with regards to the students coming
over from the community college system
have there been more of them has the
program worked the way you wanted it to
I know it's just one year so yeah it's
really
um representative it's really not rolled
out yet we're still working on our
provosts Provost are the chief academic
officers of each of the colleges
our Provost just met with the all the
Community College Provost I think last
week so we're working through different
working groups so I I don't think
there's any outcome data yet yeah
technically actually the the program uh
was given a 18-month lead so I don't
think it we're required to have met it
until next summer for exactly the
purposes Kathy mentioned it it certainly
is going to take a bit of time and we'll
you mentioned demographics
to kind of a glancing blow as the as the
demographic
makeup of the University changed
substantially over the last five ten
years
um well there are fewer students well
yeah
[Laughter]
um
I don't I don't know the answer to that
we I think we can look but I would say
there are probably two things that are
most likely to I would say we have
become more diverse
um over the last five to ten years and I
would say we have students with higher
degrees of need and that need is you
know broadly defined do they need
additional support as they as they come
to us certainly folks who have worked on
some of the education challenges in K-12
might see some of that coming along
though students coming increase
Financial need I'm sure Kathy talked a
little bit about that as part of the the
main portion of the presentation
um so I do think the demographic has
shifted a bit in those those couple ways
for sure and likely that we probably
have more uh female students today than
we did back then
thank you um just want to ask about your
International students I know when we
were when I was at Southern New
Hampshire University we really worked
hard to get a lot of international
students are you doing that as well I'm
because they pay full vote
yeah I think the international students
bring two things they bring diversity to
our classroom and experience and
certainly often they are paying high
levels of tuition uh there have been
changes on the federal level regarding
visa requirements and others over the
last
three four years plus the coveted
complication that has made that a much
more challenging environment for all of
higher ed us included
yeah so certainly still trying uh but
there are there are new challenges that
again all with higher ed is trying to
navigate
oh thank you
um we talked about a waterfall last term
and what's that look like what what are
you going to do to mitigate that problem
I mean it's I know you're going to
probably shrink some as you've already
done
the um
so we're doing a few things
um
doing work to see if there are ways to
share academic programs across our
institutions uh ways to use technology
um
we're representative it is a constant
um it's a constant effort to make sure
we right size
our campuses
for the demand
there are strategic Investments that are
being made
um
our board just approved
oh the other thing was we'd like to get
more students living on campus
that's benefits in a couple of ways it
might free up some Workforce housing in
the communities that we reside which we
know this is an issue but students are
more likely to persist and graduate if
they're living on campus
so there is um a dorm at UNH that's been
shuttered for a couple of years
our board just approved we're going to
renovate that it was a lot of deferred
maintenance it's right in the center of
Campus we're going to renovate that and
open that and
we could we definitely have the demand
that UNH to fill that so it's a it's
another Revenue stream for us but it
also again more importantly could
benefit more students to have them
living on campus and the same kind of
work is happening at Plymouth with its
um its residences
um
we want to try to get as many students
back on campus as possible because again
it's a benefit in a couple ways
yeah thank you for the follow-up uh yeah
uh we do see a trend though matter of
fact one of your competitors within the
state uh Southern New Hampshire probably
has one of the largest online
uh universities in uh in the system in
in the country actually and they do a
lot of advertising I mean they they
flush with money and uh you know you're
kind of going against the grain here you
say you want these students back on
campus
understood and agreed
um I would always point you back to
no that is the success that the
university system has in graduating its
students timely and paying off their
the most expensive education is the one
you don't finish
so
um
I I think there's something to be said
for the work that we're doing I
part of the grand State merger work as
well Granite State College is pretty
much 100 online it's almost all New
Hampshire students
um what what we in called
non-traditional students right
and that backbone that Granite State
College has
will be available to all of our
institutions as part of that merger so
we're thinking through exactly we know
we have to
be effective
in the online space but we also know
we're not going to compete with snoo in
the online space
just to clarify the question maybe are
you speaking I think somebody
representative Murray you asked this of
Chancellor is the idea of like you know
these high-level IVs are taking our
students and then we're taking is that
oh okay the demographic Cliff piece
yes and actually I didn't include it in
this but you're right we talked about
this last
two two years ago I time eludes me out
with coven
um but
we have to get to 26.
and then
if the demographic predictions are right
then we level off so we have to plan and
right-size
to 20 to the number in 26 and that's
it's a constant effort at the University
system
I think I should do that I'd add to what
Kathy detailed which is exactly spot on
and what we're doing internally right
and I think I'll try and channel my boss
president indeed and he might also add
to this you know we also need to do a
better job competing across the region
if you look on slide 12 that sort of
shows you know yes New Hampshire has an
acute problem our region has an acute
problem and everyone is is competing and
part of what we're asking the state for
this year are some additional dollars to
help us do that as I'm sure Kathy
outlined to a degree in two ways we'll
talk more about next week but we need to
do a better job showing our students
they'll succeed if they come here so
that's our graduation data that's our
loan repayment data it's also surveys we
do where right now our most recent data
is about to come out 96 percent of unh
graduates six months on will say they
are succeeding they are either have a
job or they're continuing their
education right and that is actually up
12 13 from a few years ago before we
invested in career placement services
that has helped our students both as
interns and as graduates to get into the
workforce idea really our Workforce but
to get into the workforce our ability to
show that compared to our competitors in
other states whose rates aren't as
strong helps us to bring folks in So at
the University uh recently brought on
board a chief marketing officer whose
sole responsibility is to look across
our programs uh also provide some
assistance across the system to say
these are the areas that we know we're
growing uh using data from either
Employment Security here or otherwise
these are areas where we think we can
you know supercharge our work bring more
students to us from New Hampshire and
around the country and ensure that we
continue to have vibrant institutions
that can do this work and then the other
piece of course is the financial aid
challenges and what we can do to bring
dollars in with your support to ensure
that students across New Hampshire want
to attend our institutions are able to
do so so it's it's both sides it's right
sizing internally and it's competing
Mr chair it's just a quick follow-up to
the previous comment you had about the
impact of both Visa policy and kovid on
your ability to attract International
students and you know reap the benefits
of the higher tuitions and other
diversity they bring on campus
obviously those are two things that
happen at the same time but one is more
permanent than the other one would hope
that slowly over time will recover from
kovid God knows if the feds will ever
allow us to recover from their policy
can you split a little bit the impact of
the two because again one of them is
temporary one if them is permanent I'm
just trying to understand whether this
is something that we hope will improve
later all the Visa really will depress
it for the long term so I think broadly
I'd like to get back to you I'd like to
talk to you absolutely there's offices
but like you said it's challenging
because they both happen at the same
time and then covered restrictions are
easing but not they don't happen like
that to a point that's like here's a new
deadline and now things have changed I
think we're a little ways away from
seeing covet impact and then just how
the Visa impacts at certain places in
where we were looking at students before
there's a there's a lot of nuance in
that question so follow-up would be
appreciated I understand that not all
the data is clear but wherever you have
to help us understand because it helps
with longer range planning trying to
forecast a little as much as the
assumptions are always hard to make the
conversation at the board level thank
you
thank you Mr chair could you
could your R1 status I think that you
kind of glossed over it but it's really
a big deal
what'd it bring to the school sure yeah
so uh UNH is as you mentioned a R1
Carnegie research one classification so
essentially the highest classification
of research institutions in the country
uh we are one of only a handful of R1
institutions that do not have a medical
school attached to them so we managed to
reach that classification without the
medical piece so for UNH it comes from a
largely a lot of work with NSF National
Science Foundation NOAA NASA uh and
other organizations that you know really
bring significant uh you know Research
into the state provide us with
significant resources in order to do
that work and then kind of bring that
research back out to New Hampshire in
the nation one interesting one to look
at I think for us is kind of a little
bit of an untold story in the state is
how strong New Hampshire's Aerospace and
defense industry is if you actually were
to look around the state at how many
jobs exist in that industry and you I
think you can really correlate it back
to the fact that NASA has been a close
partner with Una since the 50s we have
been on NASA Mission since 1957 I think
uh last year a 250 million dollar award
from the agency uh came to our space
science center
um so really it is we're doing great
work at the University and we are
spinning off students uh and technology
and research that is benefiting our
state and our region and that's that is
a topic that there is a lot to share and
say on that and would certainly welcome
folks to campus or we can bring folks
here to speak a little bit more to it
but there's a lot of really exciting
stuff going on I
I want to double down on that if you
were ever interested in coming over to
the university
having faculty or researchers come into
a presentation here they would
I'm sure be thrilled to accept
um
let me can I say if I could just add one
more I'm sorry um UNH as a result of uh
both being the land grant and our
research capacity also manages the
state's epscor program which stands for
the established program to stimulate
competitive research is a federal
program that ensures that smaller states
that otherwise wouldn't compete as
effectively for federal research dollars
get their piece of the pie but what it
requires of us to do is actually to work
with Partners across the state
um so we have Community College Partners
we have private institution Partners
actually some K-12 here and there to
both build up a research Pipeline and a
build up capacity across the state so
while UNH sort of gets up gets the shine
is the R1 and as the research
institution part of our responsibility
uh as a result of that is to bring that
technology and capability around the
state so it's not just us and that we're
building capacity going forward which I
think is a really neat opportunity
thank you Mr chair quick question you
were talking about the um you know um
various types of research that you guys
are doing a great job in and one of the
very um prostating things for me I live
in a you know I live in a biotech family
my Works my wife works in biotech my
eldest Works in biotech probably my
younger kid will break that Trend but
you see all those amazing research
opportunities and jobs around Boston and
we are just 30 miles away
and yet that culture there seems to make
it extremely difficult to extract the
biotech out of Cambridge and convince
them to locate to Southern New Hampshire
is there something that we can do in
terms of you know research focus on
biotech or cooperation with a private
sector that would help bring some of
those very lucrative type of opportunity
you know businesses up here rather than
on the wrong side of that border yeah I
mean I think
there are a number of folks in the state
that could speak for that Dean Cayman
probably being number one among them uh
we actually had Dean at an event last
week talking about our budget request
and what we're looking for with the
state
um and his comment was you know
essentially there there were two things
that were gonna you know impact the
ability of Army and everything that spun
off of army even over the last five or
six years to to stay here one was where
are we on the technology and he thinks
they have that settled the second is
where are we in Workforce and we can we
continue to produce the workforce that
his and all of the spin-off companies
need um and that I think every day
continues to be a challenge there is
certainly a developing ecosystem in the
Manchester Mill Yard around unhm an army
and deca and first
um there's there's work to do though and
you know I think Dean is part of a
collaborative organization I don't want
to get over my skis on this but I know
unhm is part of it and others on
building out essentially a bio life
science uh
you know essentially Consortium and that
might not be the right word for it but
how do you get all the folks in this
state that are working on this issue
around a table to talk about everything
from Workforce to housing to how do you
incubate the right companies and find
them places to spin off
um so that they can stay connected so
there's a lot of conversation to be had
about it but certainly the message we're
getting is Workforce is a top priority
and if the talent isn't there then
that's why you're going to start looking
at it I appreciate it a lot of the
talent is here they just drive south you
know I mean my family again we both live
in Windham and they work in mass and the
other thing is it really really
sucks having to live in New Hampshire
and pay Massachusetts income tax because
you cannot find a similar job in New
Hampshire and it's kind of a chicken and
egg problem so I know it's complex I
don't want to you know take too much but
can we go back to the demographics um
you know you're planning for a dropping
enrollment and you know those sorts of
issues used to be you know back in the
day everyone's kind of geared towards
going to college and that had negative
impact on the trades and all that sort
of stuff now we're really pushing you
know we need the trades people we need
that Workforce so that's is that also
potentially a decline for you and I just
always have to say I mean there's this
one girl at Dartmouth
um leaves Dartmouth with 120 000 of debt
all she wanted to do was teach Pilates
and she did not need to go to Dartmouth
to teach Pilates and so um can you just
address the disconnect and how you're
planning for the future in directing
students away from a four-year College
so the the we are Tracking not just
demographic decline but also loss of
market share that's what that is that's
what we're talking about loss of market
share in addition to the demographic
decline
um you're absolutely right
representative everyone doesn't
need a four-year degree
um so
I don't know though that we are
counseling students
that come to us on
not achieving a four-year degree but we
recognize that the if the world is
changing right that's why we have the
Partnerships with the community college
system it could go the other way you
could have a student who
um
is interested in being in the trades
and then after two years maybe they want
to go on and understand how to
open their own business so they want a
business degree in a different in
addition to so I think the Partnerships
with the community college system
are
will will continue to be impactful
I think too so there was a piece of
legislation this morning on dcyf
currently runs a a foster children's
waiver program at both U.S and agency
csnh I think right now it's 15 students
a year who are either in guardianship or
at least left guardianship have a
tuition fee waiver at both of our
institutions the legislation would bump
that to 70. in addition to uh the change
in the number of waivers the other
change was to change the age uh that a
student would be eligible from either 22
or 23 to 27 or 2800 but it's this idea
and actually a young woman who recently
left care uh testified to us I wasn't
quite ready at 22 or 18. I was ready
when I got to 25 I had some work
experience I knew I wanted or needed uh
to advance my education I think part of
what all of our institutions are doing
in the granite state merger is a big
piece of this is ensuring that we can
put our opportunities online and
continue to meet students where they are
uh be that night classes once a semester
be that you know you know more rigorous
you know some some in some out but our
ability to evolve uh where we serve the
market is also I think part of our
problem
chair thank you for taking my question
um I know a little bit about the private
educational higher ed space and I from
some of those recent meetings there's
been a big focus on
future academic areas
um that maybe weren't being taught 50
years ago and that suddenly can create a
real Economic Opportunity for
institution if they can diversify in
such a way that you know they don't have
nearby Regional competitors specifically
um I hesitate to bring this up but the
thing that I'm thinking of is that I
know there's like a Esports team
academic kind of focus trying to get
more kids into coding and to be involved
with these you know sports teams is that
something that the university system is
looking into or considering in the
future to try to diversify its you know
distinctive qualities from its neighbors
I know Plymouth is Plymouth is
um
evaluating robotics
and I know I don't know enough about
um the topic representative but that
caught there is has been a conversation
about this the gaming the e-gaming so
I know those conversations are happening
I don't know what the status is of the
programs it might be there might be at
least
yeah I know I know president Burke's
absolutely is is um
working on the robotics
and actually I think they just hosted
the first
and so I know that's an interest at
Plymouth and I think part of that
question too is how do institutions also
look at what those kids are learning and
are interested in and be sure to offer
them opportunities to what would be next
right so for you know a program at UNH
is the interoperability lab so we are a
national leader in making sure
essentially that your cell phone can
talk to your computer for example the
federal government does not buy a piece
of technology today that isn't actually
cleared by our interoperability lab
beforehand every single student that
goes through uh that in that uh program
on campus has a job on graduation right
so it is ensuring that students have
opportunities through you know summer
programming camps and things like that
when they're in lower grades say like oh
yeah there's an opportunity for me at
UNH or in New Hampshire to do stuff that
I'm interested in and I'm seeing kids
from around the country around the state
that are interested in the same thing I
want to continue my education there so
it gives them sort of a way to take that
and go to the next step
foreign
what's Esports gaming
I mean is this betting or is this
um
it's exactly what it sounds like it's
electronic Sports and um it's it's a
competitive intro interest School league
of you know athletes who
video game
different sports against each other and
um
there is a huge there's a huge market
for this internationally and nationally
and I'm bringing these teams on campus
can not only help with your title
is it 10 title 10 commitment Title IX
commitments excuse me
um for women's Athletics or you know
co-ed Athletics but um it also helps it
serves as a Gateway for some of that
higher ed
institutional instruction for you know
coding and Mathematics and you know
strategy in terms of you know leadership
and and in athletics at a different in a
what that's good what are they doing are
they coding the games are they creating
the games are they playing the games and
is someone betting on them about whether
or not they're winning like I guess
fantasy football or something who's
doing what yeah they're I don't believe
there's any
um
like state sponsored or non-state
sponsored gambling going on I don't
believe that's part of it I think it's
literally a competition of wits you know
and um there are teams that are really
gearing up to compete against their
peers from a different institution so
um I think the like the academic pitch
is that you know while you can also
participate or get a scholarship to be
on one of these teams you can also earn
a degree in a like field
so it's it's an interesting marketing
um
you know diversification that some
schools are trying to embrace to really
kind of think future forward you know
about what could make our school more
competitive in the future and meeting
students where they are in fact you know
there are students right now who are
really into these opportunities so and
it could it could really
bring a whole different kind of student
to your institution or make you more
competitive and grabbing some of those
really high intellectual
it's just exactly what you're saying
and just to add something color here and
excuse me for taking your public hearing
away
um look it's a professional sport
actually right now the money in it it's
starting to be better than the Major
League Soccer money for you know
athletes and they are people who are
considered athletes and they just sit in
front of the computer you pretty much
train for it in your mother's base you
know the traditional stereotypes but
it's actually a professional
professional leagues professional sports
lots of sponsorship money the reason why
we are not very much aware of it is that
I can assure you that everybody at this
table maybe other than Mickey is kind of
outside of the age group that is
actually monitoring those things I try
to watch well
I'm trying to show different I I shot
myself in the foot here but the point is
seriously it is actually a legitimate
sport I don't know how you know durable
it is but it's definitely a industry
around it and it's a big part of
entertainment so at the risk of this
going too much further uh
uh Exeter area and we occasionally go to
the ranks and they have uh devoted a
formerly I believe it was a rape a
weight room to Esports and you know I
think part of the interest for students
and how they might transition on a
pathway to us is they are not taking
your I'm going to go to Best Buy and buy
a computer and use that they are
tweaking these machines and turning them
into something that will allow them to
succeed while competing against their
friends or other schools and otherwise
and representative your point about
meeting students where they are is
exactly what I was trying to get at with
the idea of a summer camp and you know
week-long immersion opportunities to see
that yes there's a path for me here
there's a path for me to do something I
like and I'm excited about and there are
other kids who are excited uh and want
to do it too and tomorrow tomorrow is a
great book
and I almost didn't read it for I think
some of the stereotype we were talking
about like I don't want to read a book
I'm just going to pass along a little
anecdotal information my sister lives in
Colorado
and she thought all of the Southern New
Hampshire University as or University of
New Hampshire
so you're getting some good PR out of
that school too and as far as this I I'm
going to come back to this
there's no such thing as bad PR
the adage in the media is just spell my
name right
if you're saying bad stuff I'm still
getting PR
so I I look at this as a plus for for
unh
exactly unfortunately also hearing
stories of I will tell you we have a a
local State Rep uh whose student I think
is going to SUNY uh because of this ad
and looking at it and what they were
able to offer and what we tried to lay
out in those couple bullets is because
of where our tuition rates are which are
driven in part by state support and
because of other states willing to
invest SUNY is putting 100 million
dollars into this campaign right which
is more than our University system
receives in state funding right so they
are they are effectively poaching
students and if you look at a
competition chart you can see exactly
where everybody's looking for the same
group you talk about you know high-tech
and growing Industries every state has
the same challenge we do
um it's a really part of it is how do we
yep any other questions
well we've been very informative and
thank you
yep
well I just I just want to make a
comment if you will Mr chairman Mr
yeah Mr yeah Sharon good now uh anyway
uh my son went to UNH and because he
couldn't afford Northeastern and we just
checked it uh northeastern's tuition
right now 60 Grand a year
tuition alone
so he couldn't afford it so he said well
I'm gonna have to come back to the
University of New Hampshire
so and he did real well in his grades
they offered him an RA you know research
assistant so he got his master's for
free now what we were talking about
people going south for their jobs
he now works in Salisbury which is just
over the Border
and he lives in in Portsmouth
and he has to travel into Boston he'd be
he's building a bridge there over the
commuter line so there you go if you can
chalk one up to you on your statistics
of a very successful UNH graduate that
you probably don't have a clue of where
he's at
you know because that's that's one of
the problems we're finding with this
committee is you know they go to school
here
and or they go to school someplace else
and stay there or they go to school here
and leave so that we need to figure that
out somehow and how you know housing
course the quality of life in New
Hampshire I mean you look around the
country I mean it's got to be the best
place to live I mean we all I think we
all agree with that
so anyway but that that's that's one
that you've got to chalk up that's
interesting before we go though so two
things I think Chancellor Rubenstein
might have mentioned some of the work
we're doing with Department of
Employment Security to try and get a
better handle of how many students day
or go afterwards there is a data
challenge there
um in terms of what we can require folks
to report after graduation I do think
it's important though for the committee
to also recognize that I think the
university and the University Systems
responsibility is to expose students to
the opportunities in New Hampshire it is
in part the business community and state
government's responsibility to help them
stay you know we are the number one
Talent importer to this state this year
there are 3 000 students from across the
country who have come here for their
first year of Education that are getting
exposed to the opportunities in the
state of New Hampshire they came here
because of our institutions and because
of what we were able to offer them part
of our budget request is to help us do a
better job of connecting those students
with our business Community it's on it's
incumbent on the business Community also
to ensure that they have opportunity and
I think in our our conversations
developing this budget and in
conversations we've had with Bia and
others since they have said like we
recognize that we want to work more
closely with you to keep these students
here there's only so much we can do once
a student graduates and takes the
opportunity that they've been given and
the exposure they've been given on where
they decide to take that degree and what
they've learned we're committed to doing
everything we are we can while they're
here through internships and other
experiential education to best connect
them to the state of New Hampshire and
thank you Mr chairman this came up a
couple of Cycles ago and I don't know if
there's any progress been made in it but
how are we doing as far as
commercializing research and research
discoveries yeah uh actually because it
came up a couple times ago uh I reached
exactly yes a chairman Weiler question
uh I actually reached out to our
colleagues at UNH Innovation
um so last year uh we brought into the
university about one point uh so it's
fiscal 22 1.8 million dollars in
licensing Revenue so that is taking the
Innovation that's developed by being in
R1 and working with the inventors to put
that technology out into the state and
Beyond um so that's grown uh from about
860 000 in FY 17 like I said to 1.8 in
fiscal 22.
that's progress it is for sure
yeah and something we're very proud of
and again it's investment in in
organizations like UNH Innovation which
both works on with with students and
encouraging them towards
entrepreneurship and creates and puts
the structure in place to support those
folks on our campuses doing the research
part of our responsibility as a research
institution a public research
institution is to take the dollars that
come to us from the federal government
the state government the work that gets
done and push that back out we do that
through programs like Cooperative
Extension to ensure that around the
state you have that opportunity and we
need to do it at the highest levels of
so I have a number of uh takeaways this
was helpful so that I can answer we can
try to answer your questions when we
come back next Thursday at 11
and I'm pretty confident that uh interim
Chancellor and president Dean will be
here with us
thank you so much this has been a
terrific conversation and
you've all been so engaged thank you and
the head count thing I was curious when
you said 480 took early retirement what
was her what was your top head count
before everybody
took the retirements our total full-time
Workforce is about four thousand I'll
drill into that I'll bring some more
information on that as well like our
total full-time
you know we have also 10 000 student
employees so we have there are lots of
employees but I we're just under about 4
000 full-time employees across the
universities again including Cooperative
Extension all over the state
um but those are primarily at UNH
Plymouth and King thank you
foreign